there's a difference between what's
called harmonious passion and obsessive
passion obsessive passion means that you
feel like you need this thing and if you
can't have it you're never gonna be
happy whereas harmonious passion means
you just do what you want it's way more
intrinsic it's way healthier if you feel
like you're attached to something then
it owns you you don't own it and that's
really what obsessive passion is is
where this thing owns you and it's
actually driving the ship and that's not
what goals are for
benjamin hardy welcome to the show
yes chris
always
happy to be with you welcome back come
on it's been a while
yeah it's been uh i think it was must it
must have been during the pandemic
because you know yeah it was during the
pandemic so it had it we're not pre we
know it hasn't been that long yeah i
know yeah we still haven't ventured out
outside of a pandemic since we've been
mates but uh
one of the things that you talk about a
lot is to do with um high achievers and
performing goals and managing to achieve
stuff why do you think it is that most
high achievers are quite unhappy
it's the uh hedonic treadmill that we
talk about so basically and this is kind
of a dan sullivan concept of the gap in
the game but
the gap is where you're measuring
yourself against your ideals and your
ideals are like the horizon in the
desert so you're it doesn't matter how
many steps you're taking towards the
horizon the horizon keeps moving with
you and so it doesn't matter how
successful you are compared to your
former self if you're always measuring
yourself against the horizon in front of
you you're always going to feel like
trash um and so that's what we would
call the gap is you're always measuring
yourself against where you wish you were
and you then devalue where you currently
are when where you currently are is
fundamentally enormously further along
than your former self you may be living
beyond the dreams of your former self
but if you're always measuring yourself
against that moving horizon
then then you're always feeling like
you're behind the eight ball and that's
that's what high achievers do it doesn't
matter what they've accomplished they're
always measuring themselves against
where they wish they were and then
therefore devaluing where they currently
are yeah you say that happiness can be a
burden what do you mean by that
well happiness is a burden if you uh if
you think you have to go get it
so if you think i have to go and
accomplish this thing in order to become
happy i need to be a millionaire i need
to have that book published i need that
new york if you feel like you need to go
out and get happiness then you make it a
burden for yourself you know it's it's
not something happiness is not something
you pursue happiness is not something
you chase it's not something that
outside of yourself that's actually one
of the fundamental realities is
it's not outside of you if you're
actually chasing happiness outside of
you it's because you're you've got some
emptiness inside of you that you're
trying to fill with external
accomplishment and you're never going to
actually be able to to find it like it's
it's a it's an endless chase to nowhere
because the the hole is inside of you
it's not outside of you so if that's the
gap what's the gain
so the gain is multi-fold but in the
most simple terms the gain is is that
you're only measuring yourself against
where you were before so like before
this conversation you were telling me
about how in the last year and half two
years your podcast is 10x right so the
gain would be measuring yourself against
where you were during our last
conversation you know and you can pick
any starting point um so there's a quote
from ernest hemingway ernest hemingway
was a famous novelist and he said true
nobility is not about being superior to
other people true nobility is about
being superior to your former self
right so the gain is when i ben hardy
only measure myself against former
benjamin hardy and i'm only measuring my
gains where was i a week ago where was i
a year ago where was i five years ago
i'm tracking my gains i'm seeing my
gains and i'm living in the game i'm
actually referencing my gains and i'm
and i'm recognizing and also
appreciating my progress
um and what that does there's you know
endless psychological benefits to doing
this one of them is you know the most
immediate one people think about is well
gratitude well that makes sense but it's
also confidence because confidence is
the byproduct of past performance and so
what's that confidence is is the product
of past performance what's that mean
that's what confidence is you know you
can't have confidence in future
performance you can only have confidence
in what you've done you know and so if i
look back on my past that i actually
have written this book
then i have then i can actually measure
my past i can say oh i've actually done
this that gives me confidence which then
can initiate what i want to do next and
so you can only have confidence based on
what you've done and actually when it
comes to measuring progress i can't
measure future performance i can't
measure what i've done in the future it
doesn't exist the only thing i can
actually measure is what i've done
and so
the gain is when you start actually
measuring your progress and also start
valuing your progress um
and then from there you can do whatever
you want but now i'm playing a one
player game i'm no longer competing with
you i'm no longer worried about what the
idea is in the future because my ideals
are going to keep changing i'm just now
measuring myself accurately against
myself
which then enables me to have a lot more
intrinsic motivation it allows me to
stop comparing and competing and really
just actually playing my own game and
saying okay this is the progress i've
made what i want to make now and it
really has
no one else no one else's opinion of my
progress is relevant your opinion of my
progress is irrelevant the only person
whose opinion of my progress that
matters is me but if i'm in the gap i'm
devaluing my own progress i'm now saying
it doesn't matter what i've accomplished
because i didn't get that achievement
the best analogy is being in the desert
and looking at the horizon and aiming
for the horizon it strikes such a chord
man with pretty much all of the high
achievers that i know of that they they
chase after a thing for forever and ever
and ever and then they finally get there
and the first thing that people ask them
and that they talk about is what are you
gonna do next so what am i gonna do next
you're constantly moving the goal posts
it's kind of like
it's like being your own worst enemy if
if that was the way that your friend
spoke to you if your friend said every
time that you did something good yeah
yeah that's all right but like this this
is really that's the real [ __ ] this is
this and then when you got the real [ __ ]
they said yeah yeah yeah but but this
now this one that you you'd want to tear
the head off you would not be friends
with them anymore
no and it's it's unrelenting it's
unrelenting i mean i'll give an example
um basic example i i launched my first
book willpower doesn't work
and this is like the fulfillment of a
dream of 10 years you know like if i
wanted to write this book i end up
growing this big audience i get a book
deal for multi-six figures i end up
writing this book
and it doesn't hit the new york times
bestseller list and so now i frame it as
a failure right and so that's the gap
right i'm framing it against what it
should have been or what ideally could
have been and so now i've just devalued
all of this progress that i just made
over the last 10 years and now i feel
like a failure because it wasn't what i
thought it ideally should have been
and even with this recent launch i mean
by all markers by far the biggest launch
ever but i'm already in the gap thinking
well i could have doubled it you know so
like it's an unrelenting thing unless
you get into the gain and just measure
yourself backwards this literally where
am i now versus where i was i before
that's all i need to do two elements
there the should and the could that's
that's quite interesting as well because
those are all gaps should wood could or
all gap yeah and especially the could
because they could is is it physically
possible if you're a high achiever
you're probably going to go for
i want to start a podcast therefore i'm
looking at rogan or lex friedman or
[ __ ] call her daddy or something
that's where i'm gonna put myself out
but
by its very nature there's only one of
those people in the world there's only
one number one and everybody else is not
number one so if everyone on the planet
tried to become number one you're going
to end up failing at that you're always
going to be dissatisfied but i suppose a
lot of people get addicted to the gap as
a motivating factor because feelings of
insufficiency can propel you forward to
do hard things
yeah i mean it's it is it is a a good
fuel for people who want to
achieve or prove themselves but at the
end of the day
it will never satisfy the internal
problem that it's fueling and the
internal problem it's fueling is is that
you're still trying to get to some place
you think you need to get to in order to
be worthy or or or whole or happy
and it's never going to get there the
gap won't go away like let's just say
you actually do create the biggest
podcast now you're bigger than rogan
okay cool you just beat rogan congrats
now you're now you're now you're
somebody but that gap's now going to be
50 times bigger because now you're now
you're measuring yourself against
something else and so it's not that
achieving things is bad it's that the
gap is never going to actually fulfill
the the problem that it's trying to
satisfy
um
and so
having ideals is great having goals is
great i mean my goals keep getting
bigger and bigger being in the game
doesn't shrink my ambition
it actually just enables me to
know that the ambition isn't going to
actually make me happy i'm already happy
you don't actually set goals to be happy
you should set goals because you're
already happy like i'm not setting goals
and trying to write these books in order
to become a happy person i'm doing it
because i'm already stoked and i just
want to keep growing my own happiness
i'm not trying to you know fill some
need that is an empty space within me
you know what if people have an empty
space what if they they don't feel like
they're enough maybe they they feel like
there are certain things that they
want to achieve in life or paths and
failures that they haven't got past
they can but being in the gap is never
going to actually satisfy that
like let me give an example my younger
brother trevor he's two years younger
than me
you know by external measures people
might consider him a failure you know he
dropped out of high school got kicked
out of the military and has gone job to
job to job for the last 10 years he does
have an amazing daughter but
if he is looking at his own past and if
he's feeling like a failure and by the
way we can be in the gap about our past
as well
if you're in the gap about your past
you're measuring against what it could
have
would have should have been right or
against other people you know and so
there's nothing beneficial about
going in the gap about your own past and
saying oh it could have been something
else like at some point
you've got to actually start seeing your
own gains and creating gains and
actually just running your own race and
it's and um
so i'm all about people achieving goals
but
and and there are things that people may
really want to do there's nothing wrong
with wanting to do it but if you feel
like you need it in order to be
successful you're never going to
actually fill that need um you can want
it there's a big difference in a healthy
difference between wanting and needing
how do you define that
well if you feel like you need something
first off you have to justify it and um
it's a lot healthier just to want
something because you want it you know
you need to justify the want as well
no why do you want you don't need it
because you want it you don't need to
justify why you want to grow a podcast
you can just say because i want to
because it sounds fun i don't need to
justify why i write books it's because i
want to you know uh you don't need to
justify anything but when you're in the
game you can go and have what you want
and intrinsic motivation is about
wanting whereas
you know extrinsic motivation means you
feel like you need it to have something
else right
uh and also in psychology there's a
difference between what's called
harmonious passion and obsessive passion
obsessive passion means that you feel
like you need this thing and if you
can't have it you're never going to be
happy whereas harmonious passion means
you just do what you want it's way more
intrinsic it's way healthier
i use in the book an example of a
football player here in
america his name is and this is american
football where they throw throw like a
weird uh oval-shaped you know device but
this is trevor lawrence and he talked
about how he doesn't need football to be
to be considered a healthy happy person
like he's like if you took football away
from me i'd be fine
and so he's just saying i don't need
football but i'm completely committed to
it like i love it i'm completely
committed but i don't need it and that's
kind of a healthy detachment like in
buddhism they would say like you know if
you feel like you're attached to
something then it owns you you don't own
it and that's really what obsessive
passion is is where this thing owns you
and it's actually driving the ship and
that's not what goals are for you own
your goals you own your future you
should decide
you know you should be able to control
it but if you feel like it owns you then
you're the slave of your own goals and
that's that's an unhealthy place to be
why do you think we have a gap mentality
where's it come from
it's definitely like less existent in
kids
kids are a lot more intrinsically
motivated um
our arguments are
a few aspects of society one is so like
the gap is where you're measuring
yourself against some external reference
point right
so the public education system is one
kind of aspect of this right so like
we're in public education you're given
grades on tests right and you're
measured against other people and so the
measuring stick or the
um the reference point for your
performance is given by you know
external authorities and then you're
measured against other people so you're
already taught to measure yourself
against externals that are given by
someone else and you're also measuring
yourself against other people from the
get-go
um and so that's that's one aspect and
and then once you get like older and
older it's generally culture or society
that gives you the reference points to
measure yourself against you know social
media likes you know amount of money you
make um and so usually all of our our
reference points are externally driven
generally by culture or by you know the
upbringing we're given and we never
develop an internally referencing system
where we just start measuring ourselves
against ourselves and deciding what we
want what are the reference points that
i care about that i want that have
nothing to do with anyone else and
where it's just you running your own
race and so that's kind of where i think
being in the game starts you is once i
just start measuring myself against
myself
don't really care about you don't care
about what your opinion is of my
progress i can be respectful of your
progress i can be pumped for your 10x
jump but my opinion of your jump doesn't
really matter what matters is your
opinion of your own jump
and um
and so just getting to the point where
you're actually measuring your own
progress and valuing your own progress
and then from there deciding what you
want to do from a wanting perspective
rather than a needing perspective what
do i want to do because i want it and
because i value it
regardless of what anyone else thinks
and without needing to justify why i
wanted to anyone else that's actually
what they would call
self-actualization or or what they would
call freedom freedom to
so like there's two levels of freedom
psychologically one is freedom from
which is where you free yourself from
poverty you free yourself from you know
a bad toxic environment you free
yourself from
ignorance but the goal of freedom from
is to give you a place of freedom too
which is where you you're free to choose
whatever you want you're free to pursue
what you want because you want it
um and it takes a lot of courage to
actually chase what you want because you
want it
it's a lot easier to just focus on
uh you know trying to trying to
be successful to other people or you
know doing what you think other people
want you to do have you looked at status
and how you think this relates to that
because i had will store on the show um
a couple of months ago and his new book
to state this game is [ __ ] phenomenal
and he talks a lot about just how
ingrained our comparisons between us the
mapping of keeping track of where we are
within the dominance hierarchy have i
i'm moving up he's moving down so on and
so forth so it seems like there's an
evolutionary compulsion some sort of
adaptive evolutionary compulsion for us
to be in the gap because if without that
without that external comparison to the
rest of the people
you would just do like let's say that
you're an artist in
40 000 bc world that on the ethiopian
plains somewhere and no one gives a [ __ ]
about art but that's just what you do
you're stacking rocks up you're dead
you're bottom of the pile because you
don't contribute anything to the tribe
so there has to be an adaptive property
of this just no longer adaptive
i like what you're saying i mean one of
the concepts i've never read the book i
want to i'm going to put it right on the
reading list what's it called the status
game the study this game yeah yeah oh my
goodness that sounds great i'm
definitely sticking that right on my
list one of the things that you know dan
and dan's the co-author of this book and
by the way the originator of the concept
he came up with this idea
25 years ago because his coaching
program which is called strategic coach
is generally considered one of the
highest end coaching programs for
entrepreneurs in existence
and the only reason he created this
concept in the first place was because
he just found that didn't matter how
much his his clients were succeeding
they were all
unhappy you know and so this is this is
more
this is i would i would argue this
concept isn't initially designed to make
you more successful
i would argue there's already a billion
books on that subject
and this book is
not
an immediately optimized for that this
book is to help the high achiever who's
already listening to this podcast learn
to be happy along the way and to value
their progress but the byproduct is is
that once they get into the game
it's kind of like you train your brain
once you start seeing gains creating
more gains from your experience which is
another aspect of the game it's not just
about measuring your progress it's also
about creating more gains even from for
example traumas and whatnot once you
start creating more gains and training
your brain to see more gains you'll
actually start becoming enormously more
successful but it's without
that weird psychological need that we're
talking about where you're you're
needing to get there or you feel like
you should get there where you're
comparing or you're measuring against
someone else so it becomes a lot
healthier and you completely be free of
all of that
um but one of the just back to the
status concept
one of the and this may or may not be
relevant but
one of the things i've always learned
from dan is he said you should seek
growth not status because if you're
seeking status you might not actually
grow or if once you achieve that status
it might plummet your growth so if my
whole if if my whole ambition
is to reach some status new york times
bestseller millionaire billionaire once
you reach the status if you reach it
um
the growth may either there's no
guarantee that seeking status will
actually lead to growth but if you're
just genuinely seeking growth chances
are you'll accumulate a lot of status
but it isn't necessarily what you were
going for in the first place um i could
get all the status in the world but if
it's my goal
you know there's no guarantee i'm
actually growing as a human being you
know but if my goal is actually growth
it's not that hard to get status when it
comes to the high achievers you have to
ask yourself a question of
what's the [ __ ] point of being this
successful if i'm not happy
like what's the point but presumably i
ask i ask myself this all the time this
is i know that we're mutual friends with
greg mcewen and you know there's
uh echoes of essentialism i think in the
gap in the game talking about removing
the stuff that doesn't matter why you're
doing the things that you're doing what
are your points of highest contribution
is it intrinsic is it extrinsic so on
and so forth
but
what is the point of achieving all of
this success that you're chasing after
if you're miserable along the way
presumably the point of getting the
success of being successful to you in
your mind is that it's going to make you
happy now if happiness is there for you
in the moment why go through all of the
rigmarole of of having to wait until you
do this thing if you're climbing up a
mountain 99 of the journey is you going
up and only one percent is you standing
on the top and then as soon as you do
that you decide well yeah but there's
another mountain there that i've got to
go after
there has to be a shortcut to this
i'm aware that the hedonic [ __ ]
treadmill is a hell of a drug and we're
wired to play status games and compare
ourselves against others and it's a
motivating force and all of these things
but man if someone who isn't me yet can
master the ability to just
take pleasure
right now in the things that you're
doing and genuinely be able to look at
did i give
a good enough not even my best like did
i give a good enough
solution for me to feel like i'm happy
today
yes right right would [ __ ] be happy
then like you don't need to
to wait for something to happen you
don't have to wait to record the perfect
podcast or to have the perfect sales
call or release the perfect online
course or get the perfect book because
you're never going to get that that is
the horizon that continues to move away
yeah and and you know our argument is
happiness is really how you measure you
know if if you set a goal you know i
could set the goal that i wanted to
write this book right and let's just say
i'm halfway through writing it like i
can even though the book's not actually
finished i can measure back and say like
because i'm in the middle of writing a
book right and of course i want to
finish the book i'm committed to
finishing the book i'm writing right now
but i'm in the messy of the middle right
i'm halfway up the mountain i guess you
could say now i could be mad at myself
right now like the current benjamin
highlander i can be miserable because
the book's not done and i can believe in
my mind that once i actually finish the
book then benjamin hardy will be finally
happy i can give myself permission once
the book is done obviously knowing that
now i've got to go out and do a million
other things if that's the game i'm
going to play or i can actually just
measure myself backwards and say you
know what where am i right now versus
where i was when i started writing the
book well i've got 40 000 words and it's
pretty cool and i've changed a lot of my
belief systems even going through it and
so if i just start measuring myself
backwards and seeing my progress i can
be happy in that if that's the game i'd
rather play
and that's a much healthier happier game
it doesn't stop me from wanting to
finish the book it's not but i actually
get to love my progress along the way
and increase the value it's my current
position doesn't change your current
position doesn't change if you measure
yourself against your moving ideal or if
you measure yourself against your former
self
your position doesn't change how you
feel about your position fundamentally
changes
and what's a ball that's such a bomb in
sight that's really it that's it like
your current position doesn't change if
you're measuring yourself in the gap or
the gain but how you feel about your
current position fundamentally changes
and if you feel better if you feel the
gains and if you feel the progress and
if you're no longer on the rat race or
the the treadmill of trying to get to
the next thing if you're like this is my
game this is where i'm at i can see my
progress i'm loving my progress this is
where i'm going i know that five more
steps up the mountain i'm still not
going to be there but i'm going to be
further than i am right now and i can
then measure those gains and this is the
gains that i want to have this is the
progress i want to make because this is
what i'm motivated towards the you know
this amount i'm choosing to climb it has
nothing to do with your mountain or
anyone else's opinion of what mountain i
should climb this amount and i'm
choosing to climb and every step forward
i'm going to measure my gains and be in
the gain and i'm going to let my gains
propel me rather than the gap kind of
you know whatever
it's just a it's just a different
experience and so if people you know
wherever a person is they can either
devalue that current position
by measuring it in a gap whatever the
gap is against someone else against you
know what societies
yeah well ideal yeah or they can take
their current position and up level it
by framing themselves in the gain um and
you can do this on a daily basis as well
let's just say my goal today was to hit
5000 words in my book and i only hit 2
000.
do i want to be in the gap about today
and say today was a failure because i
only wrote 2000 words when my goal was
five and so therefore today was a
failure i'm upset about it i'm gonna
just you know today was a lost day i'm a
loser or do i wanna actually
create gains and say okay i got two
thousand words but what else did i learn
today if i can in other words you can
contextualize anything however you want
but it does zero good for you to
contextualize today as a as a failure it
does nothing for your confidence it
doesn't you get no benefits from it
you're actually literally just devaluing
your own experience why devalue your
past why not inflate the value of your
past because you're the only person who
has access to your past i'm the only
person who has access to benjamin
hardy's experiences i can either flush
them down the toilet and be mad at them
because they're not what i thought they
should be or i can increase the value of
my experience and learn from them i can
create gains from them and that's really
like how you create post-traumatic
growth something rough happens
and if you're in the gap you're saying
why did this happen i'm worse off now
because it happened post-traumatic
growth is when you take an experience
that's rough and you increase the value
of it what are all the things i learned
from this how can i be better because of
this my current self because this
happened is actually better and further
and stronger and more anti-fragile than
my former self therefore i'm glad it
happened that's being in the game that's
turning any experience into a game
how should people measure or define
their success criteria then
basically you got to create your own
success criteria what does success mean
to you you're the only person who that's
you know the more developed you become
as a person the more you define what
success means to you like my value
systems can be different from your value
system and as you grow and mature at
some point you got to create your own
value system you know you can obviously
pull it from different sources what do
you mean you know value system
value system is how you're measuring
yourself you know you you create goals
from a value system you create success
criteria from a value system you know
and so you know and you can turn a value
system into specific measurables which
you can do
but at some point you need to
define what success means for yourself
and your your definition of success is
going to be different from mine your
view of your future self is different
from mine and so
you got to ask yourself what matters to
me that's kind of it does kind of track
back to essentialism like you can't you
can't
go for essential if you can't define
what's essential to you
and so you've got to actually define
what matters to me
and then create a success criteria
around that so what's this what's
important to me these are my values
these are the things that i value within
myself and around me yeah
from that you try to create goals and
projects well there's principles and
projects you know there are principles
you can live by right one of them could
be essentialism that's a principle
that's an idea and you can you can
measure yourself on how essential you're
living right that's a that's a that's a
principle if you believe in it and if
you like it you can measure yourself
against that if that's within your value
or it can be goals you know and it's a
lot easier to measure yourself either
against a principal or a measurable
target than just an abstract ideal so
like i can create success criteria for a
specific project or even for myself in
2020
uh you know 2022. like i can
i can create success criteria and i can
say
you know in order for this to be a
success for me it's got a it's got to be
a certain way it's got a you know it's
got to sell a certain number of copies
et cetera i can create my own success
criteria right
um and the more clear you are on what
success means the more you actually can
move forward towards a clear path most
people they're not very measured in
their future because they're measuring
themselves against ideals and they're
not very measured in their past because
they're not most people just don't track
their gains honestly yeah what does um
the view you have of your future is the
thing driving your present i mean
that's a great that's a great concept
that's basically prospection in
psychology so prospection
is uh is the idea and this is one of the
biggest
unearthings of positive psychology in
the last probably 20 years
is
psychology as a discipline believed that
we were actually
uh driven by our past
now there's a lot of distinctions here
so i'll break it down
what we're really driven by is our view
of our future now this is different from
being in the gap the gap is about
measuring yourself against the future
thinking i need to be there and because
i'm not there i'm a loser the gain is
where you measure yourself against your
past but the truth is we are driven by
our future self so you whatever your
goal you know you were driven by a
future that landed you to this point
right you had a future self even if it
was undefined or defined however defined
you got it and that's what landed you to
this moment
um and you now have a future that's
driving you and i have a future that's
driving me and this is in big and small
ways in philosophy they call it
teleology basically
teleology means that all behavior is
driven by an end you know aristotle
called it final cause so like the way
that this book became a reality was that
there was some
end and that drove me to finishing the
pages right um you know even me like
even us getting onto this podcast there
was a scheduled appointment that led us
to having this call you know and at some
point you're gonna go have dinner and so
you're being driven by the next thing
and what's interesting and robert greene
actually hits us really hard in the 50th
law but this is really true is that and
also there's a lot of research on this
uh in positive psychology hal
hirschfield
the sad part for most people is is that
they're driven by an almost immediate
future
we all we know there's immediate needs
there's immediate there's things pushing
up against us paying the bills or just
getting to the next thing and most
people never transcend that and start
thinking like 10 15 20 years into the
future and start thinking about a much
bigger future to chase and be driven by
so most people are just dealing with
immediate battles you know and so
they're being driven by a very
short-term future um but we're all being
driven by the future that's what
prospection is the idea of perspective
what's the problem with being driven by
a short-term future
well it's there's nothing wrong with
urgency or immediate goals but if that's
all you have then you're just actually
on the rat race going nowhere it's like
a lot of it's a lot of movement but no
progress right
um do you have more motivation people
there's some experiments that have been
done around people's motivation levels
or happiness when they've got a broader
longer term life plan
well yeah definitely so bigger goals
certainly are more motivating than small
goals but also when it comes to the
future self research
the quality of your decisions in the
present are directly impacted by your
connection and commitment to a longer
term future self so like let's just say
a future self 20 years from now
if you're connected to that if you're
committed to that if you're clear on
that
you're going to make different decisions
than if you were only committed to
whatever is just flashing in your face
the next fire to put out or just getting
to work or to paying the bills like if
you have a longer out future then you're
going to probably make very different
decisions because the goal always
determines the process whatever
whatever future self you're most
thinking about or committed to is the
thing driving your behavior the most and
so
yeah longer longer term objectives or
investments certainly yield a lot longer
term happiness and also better outcomes
you know like if your goal is only just
to pay the bills you're not going to be
able to do something big enough that's
going to lead to something great enough
you know so having bigger goals and
having a longer term future leads to
more satisfying results end game well i
suppose what you're doing with a large
goal or a longer term goal what you're
trying to achieve
is something that takes a lot of time by
virtue of it taking a lot of time to
compound presumably it's going to be
quite big and impressive which means
that you're going to take small steps
but very small important steps
strategically to get along there so
james clear says each action that you
take is a vote for the future type of
person that you want to be so if you
want to be someone in five years time
who is able to do an ironman
you are going to do things today you
might not be able to do the ironman for
four and a half years you might only
reach that point but if that's the goal
that you're trying to move toward you're
going to do conditioning pieces today
and tomorrow and the day after whereas
what's the what's the best sort of goal
that you can reach in terms of your
endurance if your timeline is only
two months or one month you think oh
well i'll i'll set my sights quite low
and it it's not very grand it doesn't
excite us the same way
yeah so here's the here's a great quote
from um
robert greene's the 50th law and the
only reason i share this is because this
is the book i'm currently reading which
if you haven't read i think it's pretty
cool
so he says this by our nature as
rational conscious creatures we cannot
help but think of the future
but most people out of fear limit their
view of the future to a narrow range
thoughts of tomorrow a few weeks ahead
perhaps a vague plan for the months to
come
we are generally dealing with so many
immediate battles that is hard for us to
lift our gaze above the moment it is a
law of power however that the further
and deeper we contemplate the future the
greater our capacity to shape it to our
desires
um
so
yeah i mean what's interesting you know
going back to hal hirschfield hal
hirschfield being a ucla um
psychologist is his view is is that
human beings haven't evolved
to think 20 30 40 years into the future
you know like if you're a
hunter-gatherer you were mostly just
like trying to gather food for the week
or for the month like right you weren't
planning for retirement right like you
weren't thinking where do i want to be
in 20 or 30 years like you were trying
to survive the week right and so
most people are not connected or clear
on where they want to be in 20 30 years
from now and they're not planting big
enough seeds you know and then then
and there's a great quote that basically
says time will either promote you or
expose you right like if you're not
actually
planning towards a bigger future and
using that to direct a daily process
towards big term goals
the future's going to expose you your
future self is going to be way less than
it could have been like you know what i
mean
and and so time will promote the you
know promote you like crazy if you're
investing you know daily towards bigger
and bigger goals you know and every
action you take kind of back to james
clear's concept
he calls it a vote towards the person
you want to become i call it an
investment towards the person you're
becoming because everything you invest
in becomes you know it compounds over
time inves whatever you invest in grows
and so every action you take towards
your future self intentionally is an
investment that's compounding massively
and you can compound some crap you know
you can compound weeds in the garden
essentially which is just
you know every day you jump on social
media and just kick it like you're
investing and there's you know
everything bears fruit so it's gonna be
good fruit or bad fruit
i suppose as well when you want to do
something that's hard in the moment the
big broader goal is more inspiring
because it's so much further away
because you want to do the iron man or
you want to hit a million dollars or you
want to find and start a family or
whatever because you have such a a grand
goal it gives you more justification and
motivation in the moment like you're
going to be more motivated to do
something that's huge than you are to do
something that's small
and then you can break that down
yeah i mean how i look at it is
small visions aren't that motivating um
bigger visions are are motivating but
when it comes to the the actions on the
daily basis so like big vision but small
steps you know it's kind of like tiny
habits or atomic habits like
like if i have a big goal of one day you
know selling millions and millions of
books and you know having this amazing
lifestyle with my family like that's a
great vision that's drawing me forward
but if i actually want to accomplish it
on a daily basis i actually need smaller
goals
um
like again back to the idea of me trying
to write 5000 words if if that actually
was my goal chances are it would be too
big of an elephant to try to bite in one
day and i might just justify not doing
it so when it comes to actually behavior
you actually want to have
smaller goals on a daily basis that give
you commitment and momentum you know so
my goal is actually just to write 200
words today i know i can commit to that
and if i do it chances are i'll get so
much momentum alright 500 or a thousand
or 2 thousand but at least that day i
made an investment in my future self
whereas most people on a daily basis
they're not actually making progress
either because they most people
actually their vision is fundamentally
smaller than it could be i'm talking
their long-term future self
um
we all have caps on our future self but
you know there's a great quote from dan
silva he said that the only way to make
your present better is by making your
future bigger
you know and that really tracks directly
to um prospection that we're all driven
by whatever view we have our future and
the level of engagement you have towards
your present is based on
the commitment and excitement you have
towards the future
and so but then on a daily
you know you want to make it very doable
on the daily so most people have
probably got that inverted that the
long-term vision that they're looking
for is too small and the daily vision
that they're trying to achieve is too
large fundamentally yeah and so it
crushes motivation on both manners
because their big their big picture
vision isn't compelling and their daily
vision is too big
and so on a daily basis they set
themselves for failure and then they
frame it in the gap anyways and so now
they've framed today as a loss or they
just procrastinated it because it was
too big
and the and where it's taking them in
the long run isn't that compelling
anyways
um so yeah that's the iron version it is
the recipe disaster jesus it is it is
but think about it if you have doable
daily goals and you just did it and you
measure in the gain and you're like
you're stoked on it and you also are
tracking towards a massive mountain that
you're loving
uh and that the mountain will keep
getting bigger there's nothing wrong
with your ideals growing by the way like
there's nothing wrong with that we just
invite you to actually measure
yourselves against the gain rather than
the gap there's nothing wrong with
having a massive future self and also
then to quantify it and give yourself
specific success criteria along the way
um
but yeah i mean if you can just if you
knocked out some aspects of your big
goals today and framed it in the game
and then you did the same thing tomorrow
and the next day and the next day and
you do it for the next two three five
ten years it's compounding the challenge
for most people is is that this the goal
the long term is too small
and now they're trying to make up for it
and justify so they try to you know do
too much and it ends up leading to a lot
of bad days but also a lot of framed
days in the gap which then just makes
him unhappy i quite like the gap in the
game concept i first heard you tease it
on greg's show like a year ago or six
months ago or something and i've had it
in my head since then but people have
got heavily habituated framing of
situations
have you got any habits or triggers to
notice when people fall into the gap
if you are in the if you feel bad in any
way seriously
literally if you feel negative in any
way towards yourself towards someone
toward a situation it's because you're
framing it against an ideal
i'm serious it's very physical it's very
biological um if i am unhappy about
today
in any way or if i'm unhappy about my
wife or if i'm unhappy about my kids or
i'm unhappy about my team
any form of unhappiness means i'm
measuring it against some ideal
seriously like
and so
i mean a lot of times the so like one of
my favorite quotes is you never see the
outside world you only see your own
reaction to it
right you never see the outside world
you only see your own reaction to it
right so for example
my kid is throwing a tantrum and now i'm
upset
the only thing i see is my reaction i
could see that tantrum from a totally
different perspective i could try to
understand what's really going on here
why you know like i don't have to be
upset but whatever reaction i have is
what i see
i could choose instead to have empathy
right and so
if you're if if you're not liking
something it's because you're measuring
it incorrectly you've contextualized it
against some ideal or something like
that and so the way out is honestly just
practicing being in the game you know
like from a motivation standpoint
you're either approaching or you're
avoiding
it's a lot easier to approach what you
want than to avoid what you don't like
as an example addiction like i could
spend all my time trying to avoid
addiction or i could just clarify my
goals and start making small wins
towards what i want right it's a lot
better to approach what you want so when
it comes to the gain it's a lot better i
mean you want to be very aware of the
gap because it'll get you it gets it
catches us all you know
um
you know and if you're just unhappy
about something it's because you're
probably in the gap about it um you know
i can go in the gap about my kid and be
upset that he's not
doing better in his school or i can just
look at that same person and say yeah
but how's he doing against where he was
last year or against where he was last
week you know and so you can just jump
into the game i mean we actually break
down some tiny habit recipes from bj
fogg in the book about practicing it's
like you know as an example every time
you know you go in the gap and feel like
you're
failing miserably as a person
actually just pull out your journal and
write down three games from the last day
or three games from the last week or
three games from the last month like
actually practice measuring yourself
backwards on a regular basis
um one of the things you know so you
want to just actually practice being in
the game and you can do it in different
different styles
like one is this if you want to just
like literally sit down and actually
have a journaling session where you
literally just sit down and you write
down
different time frames you know where am
i versus where i was 10 years ago you
know and you can take time to actually
think about it games don't just have to
be external accomplishments they could
actually be changes in how you see the
world you know my former self
wasn't an entrepreneur i didn't imply
apply uh mon mental models like who not
how you know i was making
10x or less you know 10x less money than
i am now so like i can i had different
beliefs about money i had different
beliefs about people like i can go back
and look at my gains in my belief system
and my experiences but also in my
situation and you know and in
fundamental external accomplishments i
can do that for five years i can do that
for one year i can do that for five
months
um you can do that for a week you know
and you get to you actually get to frame
not only the meaning of your past
experiences but what you got out of that
experience and so if i just look back on
where i was a week ago
most people you know probably haven't
thought about it where were you a week
ago versus where you are now but the
truth is you're actually in a different
place you actually have gone through
experiences and now you get to go
through and organize what those
experiences actually mean
so i can actually just think where
actually was i a week ago what the heck
happened over the last week what did i
learn over the last week how am i
different than i was a week ago what are
some of the important experiences that i
had that are evidences that i'm actually
moving towards my future self you know
and i can do that on a daily basis too
you know
and so you can just practice being in
the game and so one just last thought on
this is i would invite you
you know we actually have a full chapter
on this chapter five in the book it's
all about the last day the last hour of
your day
put your phone on airplane mode because
obviously you don't want to train
reactivity pull out your journal and
just write down three wins for the day
it doesn't matter if they were the three
wins you were going for seriously you
might have had three goals for the day
and you missed them all but what are
three wins you did get what are three
forms of progress you did make what are
three things that did that did happen
that can be considered gains and then
choose the three for tomorrow and you
just get in this habit of always winning
i'm always in a habit of today was a
game even if it didn't go exactly how i
planned it was a gain i'm further along
than i was before i'm better than i was
before and what do i want to get
tomorrow it just trains you to just
create gains i think that that's just a
healthy habit to be into
yeah one of the things that i think is
going to be a
challenge to people or there is a big
difference to how most people live their
lives if they don't embed themselves in
organizational psychology is that they
need to take time away from the urgent
with this if you're constantly putting
out fires and doing things and remaining
busy and answering emails quickly and
replying on social media
there's two main strategies that we're
talking about one of them is to do with
your vision moving forward your vision
of a future and how you're framing that
and the second one is a reflection of
you in the past the vast vast vast
majority of people don't do either of
those things they haven't formalized
their values they don't know what their
goals are growing out of their goals
that are written down are very sorry
that they have a written not written
down and are very loose and kind of
ephemeral and nebulous and they're over
there and it's cloudy and then
reflection doesn't really occur in a
formal way it's the reflection is
resentment or chips on their shoulder
about things that could have what it
should have happened in the past gap
yeah so
neither of these things
neither of the two most important things
are
all that common
we're being fire hosed with [ __ ]
information and and jobs
and jobs to do every single day
and that's stopping us from doing what
sounds like two of the most important
tasks that we have to do planning where
we want to be in the future and
reflecting on what we've achieved in the
past
you know it's it's it's that simple i
mean you know in
you hear about how
you should ignore the past and the
future and only be in the present but
from a psychological standpoint it's
fundamentally impossible your experience
in the present is based on how you feel
about your past and how you feel about
your future you know like and also as
we've talked about your present is
literally being driven by where you want
to go in the future but it's also about
how you feel about your past
and a positive psychology in the present
is based on having a a positive past and
a compelling future like but the past
being positive was based on how you
framed it how you measured it how you
defined it i could have
objectively the same experience you know
my father as an example was a drug
addict you know i could have gotten in a
car accident last week my business could
have failed last week but
how i frame my pass is up to me am i in
the gap or the game right like it does
not matter what happened it matters how
i frame and measure it am i further
along than i was before am i better than
i was before have i learned more than i
knew before and am i advancing you know
and also do i get to change you know
define the meaning of it so yeah what
you're describing is essential i mean
we do need a clear future that's driving
us that's exciting and that we want to
we want to have
and
being in the game means you're you're
quantifying and measuring your past in a
way that makes it valuable and
measurable and useful and and and what's
great about it is you can
you can keep
expanding your experience you know like
i'm talking about like your own
experiences like you have experiences
right
um
you can keep going back to the same
experience over and over and over again
and getting more and more gold out of
that and also continuing to expand what
it means just back to me
me growing up in a sing my dad being a
drug addict i get to go back as the 33
year old version of this and think about
that experience and learn from that
experience and redefine what it means
and redefine all the good that came from
that
and also the challenges that allowed me
to grow and then
in 10 years from now the 43 year old
version of me can go back to that same
experience and continue to learn from it
keep evolving that experience keep and
so you know your experiences can either
happen to you or you can happen to your
experiences if you have if your
experiences happen to you that means
that you're the passenger of whatever
happens to you
got in a car accident you're unhappy
or you can happen to your experiences
and you can actually shape what the
experience means the value of the
experiences all that you learn from it
what you can do because of it what
you're going to avoid now because of it
you know you get to you know that's how
you learn
so what's interesting is the gap and the
gain aside from being a measuring model
is actually a learning model
like how much can i learn from this
experience how much juice can i squeeze
out of it if i'm in the gap about an
experience
i've just devalued it and i'm avoiding
it and i don't want to deal with it and
it was just an experience it shouldn't
have happened
and therefore i got nothing out of it
i'm just worse off because it happened
but it's your choice what you do with
your experiences
you can either be in the gap where you
measure them against something else or
you can transform them where you keep
getting more and more out of them and
keep getting better as a result it's
totally just your choice what you do
with your own your own past your past is
a fiction by the way just as your
future's a fiction your past is a
fiction
what do you mean
you make it up
literally
you're the one making up what your past
means you're the one making up the story
of it i can you know i can
you're the one who's making it up along
the way
what if someone's recalling what
happened accurately in their own mind
yeah they can recall the experience but
all of the emotions the energy and the
meanings
are are um are going to be their own
doing
those things that goes back to it's not
what happens it's your reaction to it
well that's like that's the market's
aurelius quote isn't it the universe
itself is change and life is but what we
deem it
life itself is but what we deem it and
that
that is your past
what about if someone's had a situation
that's caused them a fair bit of trauma
in the past or they've got something
that they're hung up on the way that
they were treated in school or you know
it could be a longer term the way that
they were treated by their parents and
stuff like that
what are some of the triggers for people
to transform those sort of difficult
experiences into games
100 percent i will say that the only way
you can move forward
and for it to cease being a trauma is
once you actually have framed it as a
gain
you it will be a trauma until you see it
genuinely as a gain
that you're glad it happened and that it
actually is something that made you
better as a result so as far as kind of
you know getting practical this slightly
goes back to approach versus avoid right
if you're avoiding it
then you're not going to be able to
transform it the only way to transform
something is to approach it
first place and probably the safest
place is definitely a journal right
doing it by yourself unless you feel
like you want someone to just guide you
through it you can go to a therapist or
a friend but at some point you have to
approach the experience and unleash it
right um but you can do it there's
there's there's literally prompts we
take people through in the book but one
is is just what is the experience itself
what happened
um what about the experience actually
is something you can use right
what is something you can gain from this
experience what is something you can
learn from it that you didn't know
before what's something now that you how
does it clarify for you what you want in
the future what is how does it clarify
what you don't want in the future
what else can you have learned from this
experience a lot of it
going back and reframing experiences is
a lot like drafting a book you know i
could i could spend five minutes you
don't have to spend five hours on this
you could spend five minutes just
address an experience and say what
happened
what did i you know what what what did
this teach me about life or what did
this teach me about what i don't want
what are two or three lessons that i
could get from this that can help me in
the future so that i can avoid that from
happening again or so that i can be
better as a draft one boom i can do it
again in a week
and you can just keep updating the
meaning of the experience keep updating
the lessons keep getting more out of it
but
in in psychology we call this deliberate
rumination so there's obtrusive
rumination which is when you're avoiding
an experience and all of a sudden at
some point just some random thought
triggers you and now you're just feeling
in the dumps because i just got reminded
why life sucks deliberate rumination is
when you sit down
and you look at an experience you frame
it and and what a lot of the research
shows is that it's very helpful to apply
gratitude to it proactive gratitude like
i can proactively be grateful for this
conversation but i still need to be
proactive about it i could be grateful
and stuff and so you can proact you can
apply proactive gratitude even to that
experience i'm grateful for what i went
through as a teen when my dad went
through all of his trauma and his
addiction i'm grateful that i went
through that like i can directly apply
gratitude to the experience
and gratitude for what it led to and for
gratitude
and so you you can you have to be
conscious about gratitude a lot of
people think that gratitude only can
occur because something you wanted to
happen occurred or because something
good happened you can apply gratitude to
anything
um and you want to do that with with
experiences and transforming experiences
how can people protect themselves from
complacency
when putting themselves in the gap i
know that you're saying that you mean
putting yourself in the game and putting
yourself in the game yes sorry
it's such a good question and it's it's
it's really the um
the most immediate question that most
people who don't apply this ask um no
i'm serious it's not nothing against you
it's literally when when a high achiever
and this book is literally driven
towards high achievers which i know that
anyone listening to your channel is
someone who's ambitious is it
the first question is
my edge comes because i'm an i've got a
chip on my shoulder or my edge comes
because i'm trying to get to this next
level
um
being in the game doesn't blunt your
edge
me measuring myself against my former
self and actually just saying you know
in the last
year and a half i've published three
books we've sold hundreds of thousands
of copies i've had three you know had my
last kid here's all the ways in which
i've gained and all the progress i've
made here's all my growth
again confidence is the byproduct of
past performance
confidence is actually the thing
that helps your imagination think bigger
thoughts
the more you actually live this the
bigger your ambitions are going to get
because you're actually going to see
your progress and you're going to value
it and that's going to actually give you
a much firmer belief of what you can do
chances are the high achiever listening
to this is actually back to the view of
future self their future self is
actually probably smaller than it could
be if they were in the game
um if you're in the game you're actually
like holy crap look how far i've come
what could i do next you know like
literally i mean even just thinking
about you like give 10 extra pot you
know like if you actually valued that
and really took it seriously
you're in a fundamentally different
place than your former self you're far
more capable than your former self
you're far more connected than your
former self you have a fundamentally
different mental model and way of
operating
you can
way beyond what your former self did if
you take seriously what got you here so
it doesn't really blunt your edge it's
weird the only thing it blunts is the
is the kind of
the number one it blunts you having any
really opinions or worries about what
anyone outside of you thinks about your
progress
it it it frees you from that
where it's like
you know me in this conversation
if i hop off this podcast and then go
into the gap i'm like dang i really
didn't explain myself really good you
know like you know i start thinking
about all the things i could have done
better with this conversation
that's me worrying about other people
right that's me worrying about if i'm in
the game i'm just thinking about what
did i learn from that or what did i get
out of that you know so it frees you
from that it also just frees you from
thinking you need that thing
in order to be somewhere you don't need
it no one needs it you can have it if
you want it if elon musk wants to go to
mars he can go to mars but if he thinks
he needs it because he's trying to fill
some internal need
he's never gonna he's never gonna get
there he's never gonna he might
accomplish mars
but he never actually got what he wanted
mars is just a means to some internal
end for him
i think the interesting thing here is
how society and culture put success on
such a pedestal that success can come at
any cost and success still gets
applauded so
eddie hall is a good example of this
world's strongest man a few years ago
british guy and he says that he would
have been
divorced without access to his children
and maybe dead if he hadn't won the
world's strongest man the year that he
did because he was six foot three and
two hundred and something kilos probably
on all manner of performance enhancing
drugs spending no time with his wife
being short with his kids his life would
have been wrecked
and yet because he won world's strongest
man and then decided to take a step back
and now he's a great father and blah
blah blah
people still want to put his success on
a pedestal
they're prepared for someone to
essentially completely annihilate their
entire life
in pursuit of one particular goal and
because we look at his life within this
very narrow domain of competence within
was he good
at being
world's strongest man well yeah he he
became it briefly
but if we take a broader view a more
holistic view which we can only do
internally we can't take a broader
holistic view of someone else's life
because we don't know phenomenologically
just how much misery he would have been
in to have known that his wife didn't
really like him and known that his kids
were sad because dad was being short
with them if you take that full holistic
view of your own life
the shortcut should be what is the thing
that i can do that will give me the most
satisfaction and happiness today in the
moment and again i'm watching that
michael jordan documentary at the last
dance mode
housemate put it on again last night and
i'd seen it before and i started
watching it again i love it i love that
human right it's so fun so sick
but even with that
there's there's elements and echoes of
some of the ways that michael was was
motivated
that are they are romantic you know
we do put those things up on a pedestal
someone tells him that he can't do a
thing or whatever and he uses that
motivation to fuel him
but you don't know
how well you don't know the price that
michael jordan had to pay to be michael
jordan you don't know the psychological
turmoil that he went through in some of
those situations how much gap versus how
much gain he was actually playing with
yeah and i think that
um
i think you know obviously michael
jordan is an incredible uh athlete
example
um
and again back to again the value of
this conversation it's not necessarily
to help people become more successful
i think if michael's in the game about
his own past he's happy if he's in the
gap about his own past
it doesn't matter if he got eight rings
right it's literally between michael and
himself it's between you and yourself
it's not about it's not between you and
michael
literally it hasn't you have nothing to
do with michael jordan's progress and so
like yeah you can be motivated by
michael jordan and there's nothing wrong
with being motivated by outside forces
um
but
the real value of this conversation is
how do you feel about yourself
um you know
if you're if your happiness is tied to
the future
you're never gonna get there
that's just kind of
well the other point man that we keep
coming back to is what's the [ __ ]
point of success if it doesn't make you
happy
what is the actual point of doing all of
this stuff
if the end goal of that is immiseration
between now here's a genuine question
that i've got in my head would i rather
be
unsuccessful by the standards of myself
now or society
and happy
or successful and miserable but i'd
rather be unsuccessful and happy or
successful and miserable and i'm aware
that it's not a binary choice i'm aware
that you can actually be successful and
happy well here's what's interesting
um derek sivers actually gave a really
good example of this so derek sivers was
on a you know on a tim ferriss podcast a
long time ago and he was talking about
you know one of the prototypical
questions that tim would ask people is
who are three people you consider to be
the most success who are the people you
consider to be successful right i don't
know if you heard this conversation
or even just who's the number one person
you consider to be successful and what
derek did was this was really
interesting but it tracks exactly what
we're saying he said you know the the
initial gut response would be someone
like a richard branson right someone
who's externally successful
but
what if richard branson's goal was not
actually to be a successful entrepreneur
what if his true dream would have been
to be a painter
you know and in reality he started all
these businesses as kind of a form of
like escape from his real goal kind of
like back to pressfield talking about
resistance you know what i mean like if
we knew that richard branson's true
dream was to be a painter
you know what what saber said was we
could never consider him a success like
because he wasn't being true to the
person he really wanted to be it doesn't
matter all that he accomplished if he
wasn't actually being what mattered most
to him
right
and so
that kind of goes back to like
it really doesn't matter all of the
things i do
if what i really want is something else
if i would i deep in my soul
want to be something else
it doesn't matter what that is
in anyone else's estimations of success
or in society's measure of success
but if i measure if i achieve all of
those measures of external success
according to society
and i'm still not being who i truly want
to be
i don't know if you could consider
yourself a success
right
like it doesn't matter what you
accomplished if it wasn't what you
genuinely wanted to do or believed in
for yourself it doesn't matter all of
the externals you know i could write 50
more books
but if it's not what i actually really
want or believe in
it doesn't matter like none of it really
matters you know what i mean like at
least for me i couldn't consider myself
a success unless i'm being true to what
i value or what i believe in but also if
i'm measuring myself correctly
which is just against my former self and
against my own self there's really no
one else
there's no one else that ben hardy is
competing against like literally we're
all playing our own game
like it has nothing to do with anyone
else
ben hardy ladies and gentlemen people
want to check out your stuff and keep up
to date with what you're doing where
should they go
uh just benjamin.com it's kind of just
an update on uh books i'm writing stuff
like that gap in the game will be linked
in the show notes below and you got
another one out next year as well
two next year we got uh
yeah serious workload yeah yeah but all
my ambitions blunted because i'm in the
game man i'm just kidding
uh yeah so next year we have uh be your
future self now which comes out uh in
may and then the next dan sullivan book
in the series is called 10x is easier
than 2x
which is true but we but by the way we
decided not to write that book first
because there's no reason to help people
go 10x if they're going to stay in the
gap the whole way you know why help
someone 10x their income or their
podcast or whatever if they're going to
just measure in the gap like there's no
point and so we were very deliberate to
write the gap in the game before 10x
just because if someone's in the gap
there's really no there's no value in
encouraging someone to go 10x if they're
going to stay in the gap about it i love
it man until next time
brother
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you